hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba and
I'm Tara Eriksen a couple people
referred this to me and Tara was over
today so I figured we could you know
shoot some videos and apparently on
Collider they even posted this out
Topher Grace's the star of that 70s show
and also playing David Duke
Tara's hero in the movie black clansmen
it's called star wars always many years
ago Topher Grace coming to like
experimental editing yeah and he
actually took the prequels and made I
think like a 90 minute something like
that a feature film where he took all
the prequels in the condensing into one
90 minute feature and he cut out a bunch
of stuff and it actually turned out
great
according to everyone who saw it I've
never seen it so you guys this
experimental editing and now there's
this new thing he has out and how its
pitches the Star Wars always and he
basically edits all 10 movies into one
five-minute mega trailer just knowing
how insane people talk about his like
other stuff I want to check this out I
gotta watch it and you know actually
this year alone my girlfriend has gotten
me into that 70 shows I've become a
Topher Grace fan huge fan man
really huge fan yeah and here any we got
any Topher Grace huge fans burrito for
something yeah we got great big Vince no
beef into place Topher Grace we got
Topher Grace big fans here that's the
first that's the first
[Music]
[Music]
steered as a circle makes those prequels
feel meaningful
[Music]
[Music]
cool dude is editing it's great
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
meet
[Music]
[Music]
in Australia new generation I'm like in
love with this big
[Music]
I will teach you two ways
a little taste
[Music]
oh man nobody back and forth
holy Jung
[Music]
[Music]
escape
[Music]
Jeff York's and took my nipples are so
hard with chills right now man that was
great
Tara I can't believe it
backhand the nipple touch back finger
not fun finger front is inappropriate
I did it I did it nipple chills hey Dan
that was great good that was wonderfully
edited escape your destiny I love how he
just kept cutting and showing the
parallels between the different movies
in the scenes the iconography of like
cutting a certain light saber fights and
then cutting back and forth like between
different movies yeah and showing a lot
of the similarities of the linkage and
how this is also tied in and it's a neat
fashion and he had such an impact early
on what really clicked with me in a new
hope or the first Star Wars movie when
obi-wan is talking about I knew your
father him and I were such good friends
and then you see like the prequels and I
heard I've heard a lot of people talk
about this and I find it very true they
and the prequels you don't really get
that feeling of they're strong friends
or whatever even though it should be
there because of the scenes are showing
but you don't get that but yet with this
edit whether you're cutting back between
old obi-wan Kenobi and then showing
footage of the prequels you're like
makes sense yeah you're feeling all that
this to me got me excited because I feel
like there's been a lot of sort of with
the live-action stuff a little bit of
Star Wars fatigue with the movies yeah
and this brought back a lot of that joy
and having liked it it's called Star
Wars always is this thing that's gonna
be around forever it's such a beautiful
thing and you can feel the just so much
yeah because you have like it emotional
like all towards every scene that
happens cuz now it's all mixed together
even if you didn't like the pre-cool or
one of the movies when it's all added in
together like this yeah context of the
story fully comes together and then
you're like holy crap I really effing
love story because even with solo a Star
Wars story which is the one Star Wars
movie to be considered a flaw
even using that and intertwining it with
Han Solo Harrison Ford Alden Ehrenreich
in here was like cool it was the coolest
Solo Star Wars story and has ever looked
when you intertwine it with this thing's
made the flaps look good the failures of
the Star Wars franchise actually look
really cool here the amount of mapping
out it must have taken to go through ten
movies and have to really be so pinpoint
on every single it was hours upon hours
of footage right this is a beautiful
tribute I was really surprised they
didn't put the clip in there where he's
like your name and he's like all right I
like everyone hated that they thought
was real corny and I'm like I like
there's been some upset you know
depending on what circles you talking
some don't care some do in terms of like
how ray doesn't have any of you know
like Skywalker lineage at least we know
we need to watch one more Star Wars film
but according the last Jedi she's you
know parents are nobodies and then here
it's a lot of like the first half is is
so dedicated to you know Anakin and then
Luke instilling you like this this this
tribute gave me that feeling of hope for
you know did it man like this comedy
like freaking pumped and excited in and
now we're I before I'm like yeah I'm
kind of looking for the next Star Wars
movie this made me go I'm really looking
for watching it wrap up now man yeah
they did a good job both of the editors
on this okay a new hope what are they
talking about here let's cut around the
footage with the other movies now Empire
Strikes Back let's cut around the other
foot like they did they're pretty much
going in linear order but then cutting
around to the other films but mainly
focus see if you really break down the
way they had her to do this is brilliant
I'm gonna watch this like several times
I'm gonna show this so like a bunch of
people this is brilliant guys I don't
know if this is like an official channel
they have running right here Lou's cafe
I'm gonna subscribe to them just in case
anything more it comes out seven seven
seven subscribe to the react nation
click that notification bell Tara
sit on YouTube this was brilliant thank
you guys so much you have a good day
my
[Music]